now that we can receive the position of
our physics object in the world we have
to figure out how to set the position of
a physics body which in contrast is a
little bit trickier scrolling through
the documentation you'll most likely see
a nice API called set position which
will do exactly what you think and set
the position of the physics body in the
world regardless of how physics are
acting upon it note that this type of
teleportation will ignore any types of
collision that may occur before the
position is set in other words set
position teleport you to the desired
position first and then calculates the
physics response as such you should only
use set position when you're
intentionally trying to teleport and
when you know where you're going imagine
how Nightcrawler feels so in order to
get moving with this the first thing we
need to do is once the physics body has
been created we can actually call the
set linear velocity function on the
physics body setting its initial
velocity vector so this body can be
simulated and updated properly and if
you recall we remove the velocity from
objects each frame in order to keep them
from sliding around our world like
hockey pucks as such any objects that
want continuous movement say for
instance a rocket moving at a constant
speed need to set the linear velocity of
the physics body each frame to ensure
it's moving we see a perfect example of
this in the simple projectile class
which will set the linear velocity
before sampling from the physics body